[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti
come già detto lo speaker mi chiamo
fabrizio lori e vedo davanti a me una
serie la e questo è una lettera che io
ho amato tantissimo però ho anche odiato
e adesso cerco di spiegarmi il perché
era lontano 2004 2005 parliamo di quasi
15 anni fa e i dirigenti del mantova di
allora mi chiesero una sponsorizzazione
di oggi di lì per lì e dissi ma non sono
interessato così poi quasi quasi far
qualcosa per la città perché allora non
era come oggi che c'è il basket è il
calcio allora c'era solo il calcio era
un calcio un po era in serie c2 insomma
è dire di sì vabbè dai quasi quasi mi
butto ma più per fare qualcosa per la
città ma non pensando assolutamente che
sarebbe diventato quello che è diventato
questo entusiasmo comunque partiamo col
primo anno di serie c si crea un
entusiasmo fantastico che la squadra
prenda va bene io naturalmente mai avrei
pensato di superare solo andare subito
in serie b no era un anche perché erano
35 anni che non si andava qui c'è una
bellissima foto dello stadio per dire
l'entusiasmo che li di cosa si era
creato sia creata una fusione tra la
città i tifosi i giocatori si parlava
solo di questo mantova e da lì si arrivò
a questa benedetta serie vi era 35 anni
che non si andava in b per cui per manto
era un evento privato
ecco questa è una foto che a me
particolarmente cara guardate lo stadio
che era veramente in gergo sice bombato
perché era quasi la bomboniera e appena
andati in b
molti tifosi a sfruttare qualche ultrà
mi chiese subito andiamo in a ma chi
amiamo in arrivo 35 anche i nostri che
non stiamo in b rimaniamo almeno in b no
tassi si va bene va bene c'era un po la
paura nei giocatori perché era un altra
categoria erano altri giocatori c'erano
altri stavano a squadre importanti tipo
atalanta che adesso vedere cosa sta
facendo in serie a incredibile il torino
che faccio fatica a dirlo torino e poi
c'era il catania comunque c'erano un
sacco di squadre blasonate non infine
conti matera una piccola città 48.000
persone confronto di torino berna
bologna e insomma partiamo come dei
razzi
arriviamo qui mi ricordo la prima
partita che abbiamo perso e magari
qualche mantovano se lo ricorderà è
stato in dicembre
l'ultima di campionato contro il pescara
battendo tutte le è questo che la
classifica della serie b del girone di
andata cioè girone invernale c'era
mantova 42 catania 40 questo non riesco
a dirlo atalanta 38 ma incredibile
infatti arriva la chiamata di sky
guardate bene mi chiama sky il direttore
che è passato tanto tempo sono
invecchiato non mi ricordo mi fa ma
fabrizi quale ci diamo incontrare perchè
dobbiamo firmare il contratto per la
serie a dio per età aspettiamo un attimo
perché ancora presto non fa perché
guardano non è mai successo che una
squadra che è arrivata nel girone di
andata prima in classifica non sia
andata in serie a ecco non era mai
successo fino allora capito toccato fede
cosa è successo
siamo andati siamo rimasti serie vero
purtroppo e non è più successo neanche
dopo gli 80 anni 90 anni di serie b
l'unica volta che una squadra arriva
prima nel girone di andata rimane in
serie d e quale è stata la squadra in
alto dove non importa comunque insomma
ecco qui facciamo i play off
molti mantovani su omesso di ricordo
come se fosse ieri
giochiamo contro il modena grande
partita è andata e ritorno andiamo in
finale col torino giocavo la prima in
casa vinciamo 4 2
siamo già vicino al sogno quel sogno che
io semplicemente non avrei mai sperato
che potesse succedere però stava
succedendo
fatalità cosa succede che quella
settimanali
dopo la fine di un 4 2 che abbiamo
giocati in casa una partita forse la più
bella partita come se giocare dal mio
vanto diciamo ricevuto anche il real
madrid
abbiamo vinto anche contro era comunque
giochiamo benissimo
esce sulla gazzetta un titolone scandalo
scommesse calciopoli praticamente la
juventus
retrocede in serie b dico no non è
possibile noi andiamo andiamo lì a
torino facciamo questa partita diciamo
tra virgolette onesta ma non era una
partita è una partita che era già sulla
carta
c'era qualcosa che non andava perché
manca una piccola città juve e toro non
potevano rimanere in serie b o andare in
serie b esca a scapito di un manto in
serie a lui la partita fu a dir poco
scandalosa un arbitraggio posso dire
improbabile per essere gentile e l'isi
rimase in serie b purtroppo grandissima
delusione perché sarebbe stata una
favola che sarebbe stato il bene anche
per il calcio italiano questa favola di
questa piccola società che parte dalla
c2 in tre anni va in serie a vabbè
comunque andata così
c il giorno dopo mi ricorda tristezza
infinita gli eau piansi mi ricordo
perché delle alpi piace come aveva
giocate di tifosi del mantova
perché se sapete non è facile poi
ripetersi comunque poi secondo anno di b
abbiamo juventus napoli e genova le
squadrette della parrocchia e medico
vado al calcio in settembre vado al
calciomercato che c'è il calciomercato e
dico ma vediamo qualche giocatore per
potenziare la squadra perché quando la
squadra era già arrivata siamo qui noi
ci siamo dati se poi non ci ha fatto non
ci ha permesso di andare però adesso non
sono qui per dire cose che poi incontrò
un giornalista sempre di skype si vede
che e mi dice ma presidente non prenda
nessuno quest'anno
ecco perché non dovendo nessuno scusa
abbiamo bisogna grata in finale in serie
b
ovviamente io ci tengo provare ancora
andare in serie a ma no guarin per
quest'anno non spende niente perché
tanto andranno in serie a la juventus il
napoli e il genova e probabilmente non
si faranno neanche i play off
non diciamo o è successo così prima
volta nella storia del calcio che juve e
napoli genova anni serie svagati quarti
o quinti mi ha fatto un campionato
eccezionale
però una cosa siamo riusciti a farla
adesso ti voglio far vedere cose
prego video
[Musica]
grazie
non so se fu il punto più alto della mia
gestione
fu diciamo una grande soddisfazione
questa
questa vittoria ma questa vittoria ha
dimostrato era due anni che non perdeva
la juve poi c'erano tutti campioni
modellante nafeek i mondiali per cui
c'era trezeguet che anche se giocava
nella francia giovanna juventus del
piero sono a tutti e abbiamo dato la
dimostrazione e soprattutto alla lega
che noi eravamo una squadra da serie a
questa è stato
e qui per questi ragazzi ci ha messo il
cuore e abbiamo vinto questa partita
poi sono passati anni diciamo abbastanza
tranquilla ho fatto altri tre anni di
serie b che già potere dire fare cinque
anni di b non è non è poco per una città
come mantova
poi nel 2010 ci fu un particolare un po
avevamo una buonissima squadra però non
capivamo io mi ricordo allora c'è
l'allenatore serena che magari qualcuno
si ricorda che ci trauma tavolino
dicendo ma come mai non riusciamo a
vincere la partita come non si capisce
che non si capisce finale della della
favola retrocediamo perché arriviamo per
ultimi terzo sull'isola retrocediamo non
capendo poi gli è stato un capitolo c'è
stato poi il fallimento è sotto un
capitolo diciamo abbastanza brutto della
mia vita oltre la delusione di questa di
questa poi dopo due anni si venne a
sapere che ne erano falliti perché
abbiamo dei giocatori che ci veniva le
partite e lì è stata la più grossa
delusione della mia vita perché quando
ti senti senti regolette tradito ma
tradito cerca di fare il più possibile e
poi hai qualche 12 giocatori che tra di
sconto fiducia
forse qualcuno può capire cosa cosa ho
provato in quel momento infatti per
alcuni anni non ho voluto aver niente a
che fare col calcio perché ero tra
virgolette non si può dire schifato e
forse è dire poco si è fatto era una
usato da questo da questo mondo perché
un mondo un po così
poi dopo qualche anno mi ha un po
passata e ho deciso con la mia compagna
che saluto ciao elena di fare questa
piccola accademia di calcio
dilettantistico con i bambini dai 4 ai
12 anni per insegnare loro e queste sono
le foto dei bambini insegnare più che a
diventare campioni a insegnare a vivere
ea divertirsi perché il calcio verso un
divertimento si inizia a diventare solo
uno pensa vado faccio il calciatore
perché così guadagno milioni di euro
allora è meglio non farlo è il fiore
all'occhiello oltre a questa questa
piccola accademia con asd verso che una
società di mantova di disabili ci siamo
abbiamo fatto una fusione abbiamo creato
questo che questa è la squadra favolosa
questa questa squadra e che si chiama
accademia falso loria s diverso e
quest'anno per la prima volta abbiamo
fatto la serie b a milano
noi naturalmente siamo una piccola
realtà e ci siamo scontrati contro
lealtà come esempio inter genova
fiorentina che sono tutte affiliate alle
squadre professionistiche noi questa è
la creazione affidata alla mia accademia
per cui per dire cioè noi avevamo con i
pulmini io né guidavo 1 e riccardo
guidava l'altro loro invece arrivavano
con il pullman della società dell'inter
per o abbiamo fatto un campionato
eccezionale venivano i brividi perché mi
veniva in mente il mio mantova di allora
abbiamo tutto l'inter ce n'ho a
fiorentina insomma praticamente siamo
arrivati terzi in classifica
sapete in quanti vanno su due
vabbè ma non importa perché poi abbiamo
ricevuto il premio più bello che un
presidente potesse ricevere torneo di
palla che queste premio fair play erano
45 squadre lo hanno dato noi forse
perché abbiamo fatto pena non lo so però
probabilmente no premente comunque penso
che ci daranno il diritto me l'hanno già
detto profit che non c'è l'ufficialità
perché prevede prima seconda terza poi
c'era la quarta che aveva un divario di
punti impensabile per cui secondo me ci
faranno andare per i propri in questa ci
voglio andare
scusate è comunque è un altro modo di
vedere le cose però mi è andato delle
delle gioie questi ragazzi richiamo
ragazzi speciali perché permesso
veramente speciale
anzi dirò di più ho imparato molto di
più io da loro in questo in quest'ultimo
anno che loro da me perché mi hanno dato
un senso di leggerezza e di felicità era
tanti anni che non provavo niente io vi
ringrazio spero di non avervi annoiato e
vi ringrazio di avermi ascoltato
[Applauso]